back with the boom-boom guy and a gia
Gunn back again headed to our TV screens
back back back again are you ready for
this drag race ride all over again I
don't know if I am but everybody else is
so that's getting me there and more
inspired and whether you're ready or not
here we come
yes boy yeah you are the first trans
woman to compete on the show in a full
season since rule made some comments
that then he stepped back saying I don't
think we're ever going to have
trans women compete on the show stepping
into that is there a lot of pressure on
you yeah I think it's more of a pressure
just to make sure that I am representing
my community but also remembering where
I come from and most importantly just
being truthful to myself I always say
you know because of drug rights I was
able to dive in to my self discovery and
really discover my trans-ness I think
they asked me to come back knowing that
I was the perfect person to kind of use
my voice in the most positive way
possible so that is the pressure
honestly my pet make no mistake I love
you from head to toe
now sashay away
when you got the call to come back for
all-stars was it an immediate yes or did
you really have to think about it oh I
had to think about it it was really hard
for me to make the decision especially
after RuPaul making his comment
I don't think RuPaul transphobic I do
think that the comments were taken that
way if you asked me yeah I would never
want to be compared to you know a drag
queen or a crossdresser for that matter
right this is not a fantasy for me this
is my reality and that's kind of what
she was saying today you said hey in the
premiere that you went on this journey
of self-discovery after drag race and
you did find her trans identity
was that a thing you had to reconcile of
how do you do both a hundred and ten
percent drag I think sometimes raises
these questions that are confusing
because somehow when I'm in drag I feel
less than a woman right
I actually contemplating quitting bread
not wanting to do anything with drag
anymore kind of hanging up the lashes
and you know being buried that girl
until I realized that you know you can
never run from who you are
and drag is such a big part of my life I
think I've been given this opportunity
and this blessing to really have a big
voice use that voice for those that
don't have one and just bring
representation visibility to my trans
community how do you differentiate jeah
just walking around to Gia on stage as a
drag queen I think mentally it's the
same person's versus the same person
physically I think it's very different
right during the day I'm not really
trying to be seen and trying to impress
people and have guys you know say
inappropriate things simply and just
causing attention I'm really just trying
to live my day to day life and then you
know and drag it there's a definite
motive there right right make people
laugh
to make people gag to meet people you
know oh my god she looks sickening you
know what I mean so I I would say that's
the main difference is the amount of
attention that we're trying to create
further let the game begin if you had to
sum up your all-stars for experience
with one word what would be educational
I think I learned a lot by being on the
season I learned a lot about you know me
and what drag means to me
I learned a lot about some of my other
you know dry gray sisters and who they
are personally and people and I just
think I learned that you know this will
probably be the last time I present
myself as a drag queen on television
okay and I think that's all
[Music]
[Applause]